guarda tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi
siamo sutor face quest 3 perché i
ragazzi hanno scoperto erano fatti 4 di
sì così quattro ne bastava uno dovranno
farne quattro liste rob e poi non
possono anche far finta di niente perchè
continuate a tartassarli di richiesta è
quindi devo farlo per forza ma sì chi se
ne fotte vice stars game chi se ne
fregano ragazzi sto tizio è un figo cioè
non c'è niente da dire tron lisa hanno
rubato la tron elizaga spiga e dobbiamo
dobbiamo riuscire a capire chi è stato
innanzitutto qua c'è una mina che mi
sembra mi sembrava perfetto non abbiamo
neanche raggiunta quindi problema
risolto ok ok ok sono [ __ ] genio che
secondo me dove è appena ci arrivo
vicino a dokic
no non devono pagarsi in toglietemi st
chiazzolino ok va fatto da solo a posto
primo livello completato il primo di
tanti vai click mi applico perfetto sono
e roero sicuro lista cosa perché cazzo
l'ho fatto che effettivamente questo è
difficile non lo sto capendo non impara
non devo cliccare sto coso perfetto come
capito che cosa devo fare
datemi una cazzo di mare e un'ora che
esplodo a caso non so non lo guardo le
soluzioni [ __ ] nome nei guai ma
chi cazzo è una donna che bella gnocca
ma vedo anche che qui siamo straconi di
fronta io ho una mela tu hai due pere e
ci siamo ragazzi più o meno come posso
rimorchiare questa bellissima donzella
tipo con una mela e non ti caccia va beh
allora la mela non la vuoi
però mi dai un bacio a voi la mela
mangiata cioè mi devo mangiare la mela
adesso la vuoi perché i ragazzi non
accettate mai mele dagli sconosciuti e
soprattutto se sono morsicata maggior
ragione questo ve lo dico io comunque
dovrà aggiungere la bandiera ottenuta è
difficile vai così vai così o lei sa di
merda adesso se vado su il traguardo al
contrario ce la faccio lo stai se minuti
e che il tenti di trovarmi così perché
sono troppo pro
allora facciamo le cose come si deve
no no ce la posso fare lega non è
difficile
piano si sporca trova bene non era così
difficile ragazzi stiamo andando da di
over perché c'è un carro armato
cos'è sta roba ragazzi sticazzi devo
sparare secondo me anno vado a piedi
vado a piedi nel dubbio vado a piedi c'è
problema allora sono sott'acqua con la
mafia è bellissimo che per il bello che
c'è la maschera per vedere sott'acqua ma
non è che c'è un respiratore come cazzo
respirare non facciamoci domande
regaliamo avanti così è morto è ragazzi
è bellissimo perché se non aspiro non fa
nulla ma se respiro
muore a caso è che cosa dovevo prendere
qualcosa una roccia un aereo qualcuno mi
salvi magari se fosse un sottomarino mi
fa un favore già che prima cerca solo un
cazzo di genio ragazzi non so come mi è
venuto in mente sta cosa non chiedetemi
ma questo tizio si sta letteralmente
fissando addosso tranquillo zio ci penso
io a salvarti non ti preoccupare
va bene un importo è stata una bella
vita chi se ne fotte andremo a ciccì
coccò tre civette sul comò che facevano
rosario con la figlia di cat mario vabbè
comunque facciamo due è morta e mame dai
fissero tutti felici è fottutamente
contenti almeno va all'amiu gyum style
fai qualche ragazza andato ho cliccato
ho trascinato il mouse praticamente si
spara spara vuoto dove va
ma no ma cazzo è morto anche lui ovvero
andiamo avanti così è inciampata tutto è
bene quel che finisce bene quindi
andiamo avanti dai ragazzi oggi vi
racconterà la storia di newton colui che
era seduto sotto un albero e grazie alla
mela che li cade in testa gli uscì un
bernoccolo questa è scienza
io ho sempre detto che la scienza fa
male ma nessuno mi ha mai creduto
comunque come dovrei fare questo metto
sradicare tipo l'albero sono convinto
devo criticare qualcosa che non sto
vedendo questo è sicuro però non la vedo
ecco infatti un sapevo cos'è sta roba
ma sti cazzi va bene non pensavo così
tanto addirittura vabbè ci siamo siamo
sullo stesso albero di prima ma stavolta
c'è un gufo
cioè no c'è un picchio scusate che cazzo
dico vabbè comunque mi scusi uno che non
volevo stavo facendo un po di amicizia
con l'albero non con lei
vabbè comunque a buongiorno senta lei
sia per caso
adesso voi mi spiegate perchè perchè è
un tizio dovrebbe camminare come un
ebete andare a sbattere perché perché
ragazzi sta cosa non la capisco si
guarda dove vai bravo tornatene indietro
ok va bene non era così difficile io lo
share this game non condividi questo
gioco si prova condividete il video
possiamo dice il meme no vabbè basta mi
piace comunque ragazzi siamo a cos'è un
telefono chiama mi chiamo al 911 anno fa
c'e scritto pilot road 3 3 2 2 1 1
perfetto 3 3 2 2 1 1 anno era 333
sull'amica sono un deficiente 3 3 3 2 2
1 1 ragazzi 4 cazzo di ora che ci sto
provando lordate minavano va folco
guidando i telefoni fissi con le lettere
porca traina magari a me devo scrivere
magari troll non per pr ll sì che cazzo
allora era nata bene banalissima come
cosa lo sapevo ma la matrioska su trofei
perfetto ma ci scommetto il cazzo che
volete che controlla
no è uscita una merda va beh più o meno
aiutate ho capito che tanto c'è qualcosa
che non c'è qualcosa qui che spunta però
non molla donna d'onna bello forte sta
roba qui non si capisce
c'è qualcosa che tipo di l'avevo
fottutamente perché poi al suo fascino
control super sayan comunque è devono in
cosa è sta roba
c'è una piantina bellissima che io
estinguere i così non ne voglio uscire
allora facciamo così
sì di nuovo così si che bello ragazzi
sono giannini ha fallito in partenza
facciamo così prima torniamo su e poi la
ributtiamo giova bene magari qualcosa
serve l'altro in pianta perfetto yo yo
da domani voglio il vaso di sta roba di
farti capire perché sono troppe queste
appieno gli alberi non la capisco sta
cosa che io gli diro le ha accettate
questo ride fatevi capirex sente perché
se uno tira un accettata così ad un
albero dovrebbe stradi carlo perché
dovrei intanto c'è qualcosa c'è un
albero ha per te li faccio solletico
ragazzi da domani tutti in giro va a
cercare di fare il solletico agli alberi
perché vi giuro che funziona ho scoperto
un modo efficace per diventare più
intelligenti non l'avrei mai detto fa
veramente piacere sta cosa però mi sa
c'è la lampada quindi aladino doveva
lurida l'acqua da di carlo torna a cui
subito lega come vi prego qualcuno mi
spiega il cazzo dovrei fare che sono una
mezz'ora qui coast occhio che ballonzola
modo hanno chiuso a caso ho fatto questa
cosa non l'ho capita l'ho girata
dall'altra parte c'è interamente devo
dire a madonna santissima cioè che cazzo
serviva l'occhio fatemi capire livello
16 ne mancano quattro regate devono devi
andare devi andare al finish al finis
dylan ma guerra seguito vero beccare sti
decerebrati mentali dove di dove sta
scritto finish grosso come una casa
bradley devi andar lì ok no no no no
sicuramente come faccio a farla andare
avanti ragazzi a casa magari 12
lo sapevo lo sapevo lo sapevo ci avrei
scommesso qualsiasi cosa vedovo far
questo era come l'altro c'è una c'è una
valvola
sì mi diverto con poco perché c'è una
valvola fatemi capire
devo cliccare qualche matto aim al m da
io sono stupido se ho finito la presente
perché continuava a girare la rotella
come un [ __ ] poi alla fine ti
apparirà la scritta giusto achache di
nuovo newton ragazzi ma il cocco cocco
il cocchio ragazzi ogni otto alloggi non
te ne va bene una mi dispiace facciamo
una colletta compriamo tutti i momenti
da newton perché ci avrà mal di testa
nella madonna dopo st giornata che gli
chiedono frutti in testa che questo c'è
un tizio che chi cazzo mi fa piacere che
c'è anche lei in questo gioco bellissimo
senta mi sa dire come faccio a finire
livello per favore magari devo fare
magari devo farlo cadere
col cocco in contemporanea si ragazzi
sta cosa non aveva senso come del resto
anche gli altri 19 livelli compreso
questo cos'è devo prendere il primo
tasto il secondo tasto il terzo tasto
cos'è ragazzi sta cosa non la sto
capendo siamo al penultimo livello ma la
vedo difficile
cosa dovrei riuscire aggiustare
televisione o capitolo fatto anche prima
non ha funzionato quindi non ha senso
cosa può fare qui sì ho capi non fummo
donna allora non funziona lo capisci che
non funziona ci ho già provato da fa vj
tv non funziona casa allora dobbiamo
riuscire a fare qualcosa perché è uno
scempio
non posso avere avere tipo a caso non si
possono prendere a casa i pulsanti si si
si è visto da quanto tempo amico mio
amico dal secolo e non ti vedo anche se
lui è un po più troll bis che elvis ma
non importiamo all'ultimo libro minchia
dopo secoli ragazzi al ventesimo livello
se hai rubato l'atro lisa brutto
bastardo dammela ai leasing sport five
difference quindi devo trovare cinque
differenze ok allora la prima sono i
denti la seconda sarà mica il corno la
terza all'occhio ero sempre bravi ste
cose la quarta perché c'è la bottiglia è
l'ultima è il fatto che ha meno tette
magari sta tipo nella cornice o nello
sfondo perché mi sembra troppo strano
dove cosa è l'ultima non lo sto vedendo
ragazzi allora le tele tette non sono
perché quello visto subito che sono a
posto ragazzi l'hanno capita sa cosa
marcazzan a [ __ ]
ma va da via che dopo regala solo
perdere quello che appena successo
perché non l'ho capita abbiamo
recuperato la tra lisa è la cosa ebbe
siamo troppo forti cruz del crollo
abbiamo rubato un'altra statua stai
divertendo vero alle mie spalle ti
diverti brutto stronzo ragazzi non ho
capito bene se nel 4 questo dove ha
rubato la statua non lo so comunque se
anche trophy squadre sappiate che farò
anche quello perché mi sembra esagerata
mente intelligente come gioco non
trovate anche voi che ragazzi come al
solito mi mancano ugo però se doveste
sincera ma va bè ragazzi dire che
possiamo concludere qui sel video è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato
argomento mi piace anche la fagiani alla
pagina alla pagina di facebook come non
i video trovate nella descrizione senza
seta tristi iscrivetevi noi ci vediamo
un prossimo vinto bene ragazzi